it was a shocking story when it made
headlines in April an alleged cult
leader and former Network TV star both
arrested on sex trafficking charges now
the inside story of the organization
including Revelations of some prominent
clients is being told for the first time
in the sex cult that preached
empowerment the cover story of this
Sunday's New York Times magazine author
Vanessa gregoriadis was granted
exclusive access to the group Nexium
shortly before federal indictments were
issued and she is here to tell us all
about it Vanessa good morning good
morning so you had this access 14 years
nobody had gone inside and give us some
basic idea of what you learned about
this organization and its leader as well
well Nexium is a group of mostly
affluent women some actresses living in
a conventional suburb outside of Albany
just looking like you and me going to
the gym driving their BMWs but they
believe that they're on a path to
Enlightenment and for some of them
Enlightenment involved having sex with
the leader Keith Ranieri tell us about
the leader Keith Renee I thought he went
of like a nerd I mean almost a professor
Professor he thinks he thinks herself as
a great philosopher and scientist and to
him this was a human experiment that he
was doing with all of these people to
see if he could heal them of their
traumas in addition their sexual traumas
that's the way he saw it I believe it
gained a lot of headlines because
actress Alison Macker people knew from
Smallville was also caught up in this
what was her role in this group you know
she was a spiritual Seeker from the time
that she was on Smallville so she truly
also believed she was on a path to
Enlightenment but the FBI thinks that
she was bringing younger women into the
group
for the purpose of having sex with the
leader how would you describe as we may
as as Dana mentioned was 14 years since
they let a journalist in it how would
you describe the atmosphere in this
community
um it was certainly tense I mean they
were very aware that there could be some
indictments um they were extremely
paranoid they tape recorded all my
conversations with them you know and
they also felt extremely misunderstood
they wanted to tell me that all they
were intending to do was help people in
the world but this was also a pyramid
scheme that was going on as well this
wasn't the reason it was founded or was
it by Ranieri um well you know ranieri's
motivations are somewhat unclear you
know like a lot of leaders like this
through time of course he was interested
sexually in some of his followers but he
had previously in the 90s run a company
that had you know State Attorney's
General thought was a pyramid scheme so
he had some you know past in that kind
of business as you mentioned this
attracted some very affluent people from
some very prominent families what was
the Allure here do you think
[Music]
um I mean I think that people just even
want to be healed they want help and he
was able to get into the cracks of their
lives and where they felt insecure and
make them feel that they were part of
this new family and you know it was a
community I mean that's where did this
go where did where did things start to
go wrong do you think
um well you know the FBI thinks that he
had 15 to 20 girlfriends through all of
this time most of the group actually
thought that he was celibate the people
that didn't weren't in the inner Inner
Circle didn't know in the last couple of
years you know they he really fostered
these secret relationships and called a
lot of the women slaves who were in
these relationships you know potentially
with him or being groomed to be in
relationship with him and those women
thought that they were simply there for
self-help
it's a fascinating article for Vanessa
gregori Addis thank you so much for
being with us this morning